um all right thanks everybody that was
that was quite hard for me
all right um i'm stephen
it's so quick to be here and i'll be
speaking
on scientific speech modeling for sign
language understanding so in this talk
i'm basically going to
the entire process i got started
building it and then the killer scenes
that i learned by building it uh yeah
but first of all like i think i want to
give a shout out to the organizers for
organizing these events i mean it's
quite i mean i joined the first session
and it was quite um amazing yeah and
then
i've been corresponding with some of
them um via muse i think uh there's
alessia there's alexander yeah so
thank you to all of them for putting
this together
all right so let's get started
so the project started out as a phone
project but it's an insulin working
prototype that detects
sign language meanings in images and
videos and generation equivalence
voice of words that has been
communicated by this channel everything
in real time yeah so what i did was to i
wasn't conversant with sign language
before so
what i did was to
go to google
yeah and then try and learn um some few
signs i think it will nice sign works
and yeah so that was how i had my first
data set
to start
to build the first one project and then
yeah it was a challenge on twitter
there's this company known as the quest
so it's an open source of
ml engineering platform yeah so
so with this i was able to win the
challenge and then um so that got me
thinking because as at that time i was
thinking of transitioning into uh
into machine learning research so i was
like okay could i possibly spend this
job as a
machine learning research project so the
the first person i talked to was my
friend okay so she's a researcher at um
data science nigeria data science
nigeria is like one of the biggest um
um most prestigious uh
uh data science and ai communities in
africa
so i talked with her and then since she
said this is in recession so she sort of
gave me tips and guidelines and then um
yeah so that's how i got started and
then it's gonna get based on our
guidelines i i talked to my
mentor
so
dr bobs
is a is a senior lecturer at scouting
metropolitan university so
with both of them i started scooping out
the projects once enabled with such
projects is that you have to have
a motivation i mean a problem space
that's
uh i mean your problem is without your
project needs to be solving something
something that
has not been addressed by previous
research box so with them i was able to
you know outline what i wanted to work
on and then yeah so i'm a collective
gaming so i i don't have anybody in the
audience about the web collected before
but
it's it's like an open open science lab
you know yeah emily is a chance from all
over the world to write home you know
playing collaborate and just do stuff
together yeah so i'm a collective um i
joined the collective at the start of
the project and um yeah they were very
you know
um enthusiastic about me scaling it up
as research work and
based on their i think i got completely
so seasoned yeah but i have found some
feedback from there
so and finally the mayan stack seminar
is a is a matter starts finally starts
the university of toronto he already had
about seven
publications or even as an undergrad so
he's a researcher
and then yeah it kept me mostly with the
academic writing and literature with
people
okay so moving on
in the end we thought if they've
accepted into uh the workshop but new
leaps
knowledge is like one of the more pretty
prestigious
uh machine learning conference academic
conference in the world right now so
regardless of the workshop
and uh i think this was last week sci-fi
sci-fi thanks me email for telling me
that this paper was also accepted as a
conference paper and some
insight by proceedings
okay so uh in this slug now that we've
covered the you know the old
motivational
so
collaboration
i'll go to the background the data says
the experiments carried out and then
finally i was found she was a demo
so um concerning the background so we
needed the motivation and then
after an extensively social review i
we decided to you know focus on things
and the aim is to reduce the
communication barrier the young employee
community and the larger society with
the focus on sub-saharan africa we
discovered that sub-saharan africa is
like the region with the most cases of
young disabilities and then
simultaneously the region with the um
lowest nominal solution speaker target x
was solving this yeah so our approach
our motivation was to try and you know
mitigate this communication barrier
in the region
so and then based on our literature
video we discovered that the lack of
solutions for this program in
sub-saharan africa is most leading to
two factors and the first one is that
the sign language data in the region is
estimating results yeah prior to this
there is no reproducible or
substantial data set in the region by
yeah so
um and secondly there are increasing
complexities that are constitutes they
have to deploy some of these uh
solutions in life environment for
example some solutions require you
making use of smart gloves you know
magnetic laws and yeah in a region where
uh
uh where the standard of living is you
know it's a little lower than average
then being able to you know make use of
these complex tools might be um if
heritage
so based on the based on motivation we
decided on um following this approach so
the first step is to quote a novel data
set or sound country sign language and
says i'm from nigeria it makes sense an
idea is simultaneously the uh most
populous
country in africa as which are in
engineering sign language and then um
assigned to test conversion experiments
several models and finally deploy the
based performing model for return usage
once in the sign works to
to test some speech okay so um
for the data set uh over 8000 images
requested
right
yeah and we did this with the up on the
tv side broadcaster yeah and then
um
and then
i used my first um model which with the
city sign language
forecaster data and so once i had the
proof of concept it was easy reaching
out to um schools i mean special
education schools
in my
my local city yeah and then
request them to you know integrated
elijah different sets and then yeah so
most of them were quite enthusiastic
about that and in the end it settled for
two schools um yeah so in the end this
this is what we had we had um the widely
dispersed data set of 20 individuals uh
captured in diverse background and
lighting condition we have to blow the
faces out because there's the um
there's the identity concerns
now
yeah so um for the data processing like
we just say uh the data cleaner we just
take images to i think 5000 images and
then uh
we since we plan on using object
detection for some of our models so we
made use of label img which is a
a graphical notation to
use an open source tool and then yeah
right we made use of that to analyze the
images for detection inputs test and
from us
yeah so for the experiments we uh tried
our different models and the first song
we tried out was the uh yellow fight
model right so i don't know if you're
familiar with anybody's family i've been
showing you that
but it's like one of the state of the
art of the detection models i know
so
we also tried out a single shot detector
using a snake 5015 and finally i
discovered the
um the annotations files and just made
use of the images to build the
classification model using combination
all right so for the yellow model
i made this of customer annotations and
then data augmentation methods like hsv
manipulation stations we simply
means a huge saturation from value
modulations and then
what he's doing is simply
manipulating the lighting conditions of
the of the images
so and then they're scaling you know
just simply zooming in on so many
times there is left and right flicking
okay so we think about over 150 epochs
patch size of 16 and uh so this is what
we were able to have you can see that
the recon score is
almost reaching uh
i think they have 99 and then the
precision score is on 87.
uh yeah so we also have the uh map
which is a main mean average position at
0.5 iou and min average decision that's
0.95 iou so what it simply means is that
there's a boundary box down the sign
yeah so there's the true label between
the box and then the model is predicting
uh
is predicting uh you know
another boundary box so we try to um
try to check the overlap of the degree
of obama between the um between
two boundary boxes and the predicted
boundaries so this was at um at fifty
percent of allah and this was at
yeah
and
you'll notice that the 50 develop is
almost close to
99 yeah but yeah and then the
the 95 percent of all up is like 67
percent
accuracy
yeah so for the ssd model i made this up
i should mention that the yellow b5 was
did was done with um high touch yeah but
for the ssd mode i had to make use of
tensorflow
specifically the software detection api
to process and finds on the uh resonance
model
the the us nets 50 was between was
already present on the purple 2017 data
sites and
yeah so
i had to convert the image and
annotations to cf record formats and um
for the edit augmentation techniques i
already made this of course clicking and
then zoom in and then i extend of course
40 000 steps
yeah so finally for the classification
mode there i made use of mobile pictures
of classifier and then in the first try
i only made use of 60 ebooks of training
using 50 feature instruction feature
structure simply means that i'm using
the within mode of mobility b2 as my
as my feature instructor so i'm only
putting a single desk layer on it so i'm
not i'm not fine tuning any of the
previous layers that are containing
mobile
and then uh secondly i
trained that was on 40 ebooks of
training and this time around i
fine-tuned some of the layers in the
model mobile address was 152 layers and
actually i fine-tuned the last 52 years
while leaving 100 layers frozen
so this is what i had in the end so i
did this light this green green line
denotes um the point where i start
finding all right so you can say that
they lost was crazily i i mean before i
started the old friend seriously
yeah and then
once i started fine-tuning it just
drastically climbed up here i couldn't
explain this and then um
yeah they decreased the game yeah so for
the swimming accuracy i mean that was a
steady um that was a steady um rise so
it's um experiencing this sharp rise
coming over
and then uh yeah so for the recall they
give colossal experience that is
radicalized once i started the fine
tuning stop
and um same as the precision
[Music]
so finally this is my um
this is my matrix table so i for the
game called you can see that the yolo
was performing test and then
uh when it comes to the my five percent
uh iu is also performing very well yeah
so the classification mode they also
performed extremely well i wasn't really
considering classification initially but
stunning one of our research terms on
segment collective um one of the season
researchers gave me
you know that suggestion to try out
classification and just say
detection models and i think i was quite
surprised to see the classification
model performing as well as the
yellow model
okay so i deployed the yellow model
since this was my best performing model
and then i did best to test conversion
with itt exterior
then i deployed the model on digital
server this data server is simply a
wrapper and docker so i'm basically
using docker for my links
all right so um yes the demo
okay so uh in the right hand side i'm
spinning up the diffstack server as you
can see i'm using docker to do that
yeah and then i'm using it to point at
the best performance model and over here
i'm running the live sheet section
and what's basically doing is that i
need this of opencv to open my webcam
yeah
and then um and then it starts um
it starts um
capturing hey
i was thinking of trying to form a
sentence with uh i
sorry
sorry
okay sorry that the
old uh you know sign emotion was in fact
explains yeah i'm not i'm not yet a very
plain designer so
uh so that means my i mean the reason of
my own is standing over several image
frames yeah so that means it's getting
it depends i is getting edited uh
three or four times yeah so one thing i
want to i i like calling attention to is
that
uh for the data set that wasn't part of
designer on this particular background
has never been seen before by this model
and i don't know if you can see this but
i i have a light over here and what the
main purpose of the light is just to
distort the image so that the model
would have at that time is trying to
recognize this sign and then the model
still you know perform admittedly
despite of the you know all the um
general generalization challenges that
are imposed
okay so uh moving on some of the good
blocks i contact
yeah i mean
this was like the hardest part of the
entire process yeah i also write letters
continuously so you know
this broadcasting profession before i
could add someone signer and then um for
the schools i mean i also i had to you
know go on emails receipts and then show
them my proof of phone stats then i
asked about a lot of laptops my friends
and sisters laptops so we would have
multiple laptops the
little situation at the same time
yeah and the deeper annotation was even
more hectic i mean i had to annotate
over 5000 images by hand
yeah so that that took us about this
yeah and then um currently i'm trying to
sort out the datasets when i
when i submitted the
and submitted the uh the work you know i
wrote it deeper so when i accepted it
because news and this new absorption so
so one of the uh one of the reviewers
suggested or commented on how i how do i
plan on you know trying to
protect the sinus identity and of course
i had the active agreement every time
but
i understand that stuff like that i best
you know put in a written agreement
yeah so um currently i'm trying to sort
out the data sets for this i've never
really gotten around to it yet because
i'm increasingly busy yeah so finally uh
a big shout out to a collective for the
complete resources grants initially i
was making use of a
collab for my training and if you're
familiar with cola you know that is an
interactive uh development environment
so you have to be on it
constantly typing and if you're leaving
it for so long to train then maybe i
don't know in 30 minutes or in two hours
time is either going to you know
disconnect automatically or
or it's going to you know actually stay
there so that means i think for the
first 20 i had to stay in front of my
laptop for 13 hours straight up i've
been watching my modern feeling and
keep telling about any pull up that's um
i'm right there
yeah so uh some of the lessons that i've
learned
one thing i think is like the biggest
for me uh most times we only need that
one project you know
for whatever it is you want to do say a
beginner and i don't know you want to
get into the
professional space or or your startup
founder or your
your academic etc yeah so most times we
only need our own big projects to put
our names where we want it to be or you
know
to get access to opportunities yeah i
would say that since um since i got the
people published on the
um
at the near west conference i i think uh
the amount of effort
since then skyrocketed by i mean i've
had people you know going out of the
race with me and i realized that okay
most times people just want to see their
potential they want to see you do
something very cool i mean seeing is
related so it's easier for you to see
your head when you've done
something substantial yeah and um since
then i've gotten quite a number of you
know job opportunities yeah i've been uh
i've got to mentor
i've got a lot of stuff to do this
project i think last month
um i got the ai champion awards for the
nigerian computer society and yeah
so yeah so i think that's
that's like my biggest takeaway from
this project most times we just need
that uh one big project to put on our
names wherever we want it to be and um
yeah so and also maybe we can find out
what we really want to do by getting
that uh one big project done so i i
realized that for me i wasn't too sure
the direction i was going to take yeah i
mean
i i have multiple skills i could work as
a you know software engineer with the
focus on machine learning i could work
as a function
i work as a data scientist but
through this project i realized that i
really want to be a scientist so that
means that i'll be going for phd if i
really want to do that then um
um yeah i think i get i got that
qualification you know by working on
this big project seeing the results and
yeah so that big project will uh most
times they find what we really want to
do you know
in life
um also yeah so knowledge of that thing
let's just start phones we you know have
the right to do that
for one i
when i started the project i was i
wanted to get into research that was
like i got started right and then um
when i finished the project that was
when i saw this um this charts by one of
the
uh
more prominent researchers
in in the u.s right now and i saw this
chart and the chat is that when you
start massage the first step is always
reading papers and then you try to write
articles blog articles about what you
read and then
yeah so and then you try to eat the past
as much as you can and try to find that
spot
that has that hasn't been covered yet by
any research and then you try to do work
in that in that space and
for all this timeline i think there's
like a year now
a year to get enough um space for you to
get your post to such paper
and mine was actually a little bit
different because when i started this uh
i didn't really know much about research
i just got started
yeah i had my first disaster in i think
for four months yeah four months of
crazy work yeah so what i'm just trying
to say is you don't need to advance most
times of course elaborate planning is
nice but most times i think it's easier
for you to just get started not knowing
the implications or the knowing how hard
it gets done for you to you know know
everything that it entails our ask
things to
get and then normally you know most
things uh most things are then our uh
when as a way of um
getting afraid you know having these uh
flights um
this flight um
this flight is feeling right to take
flight and then you know we start
procrastinating now we don't get on time
okay um finally uh we can our phone have
been you know save the world at the same
time yeah i think i've seen people uh
investigating ceos online you know
um trying to sell their projects or
products of us you know
uh making the world a better place you
know when the focus is actually
different um
and most times i i think most people try
to um segregate this who they too i mean
you can have fun but
fun is different from you know you've
been trying to um save the world i've
seen people be like okay you can make
money but um yeah most times people
trying to save the world it's not always
about money but i i think you could you
know to go at the same time without the
uh that one you want to have you know do
something find something that is that
can be extremely useful
both
all right so um thank you very much uh
so if you want to check out the code and
profit files or you just want to
run this demo at your end yeah so the
link is inside there um and also if you
want to read the clip up the print on
archivia the lego system
thank you very much for taking your time
to listen to me
thank you very much stephen
so now we start with the q a session um
as i mentioned before go to slido.com
enter the keyword pi ber like berlin the
first three letters and then ask your
questions so we already have three
questions here steven the first question
is what was your validation train split
oh
yeah for the validation twin splits i
i made use of
you know um for defense data made use of
train val on the contest right so i i
made this um
80 10 10 since my data set was quite
large at least to a good extent so 80
percent was a 20 data and then 10 was
the validation
10 was the validation on
another 10 percent was the
test test data
okay thank you the next question is did
you already develop this into a mobile
app or how do you think about deploying
it to the society
yes i think i got to ask the same
question at the nigeria contest society
ai summits so yeah i've been thinking of
of deploying these as a mobile app so
i'm currently talk with a mobile
developer about it but they seen this
i've gotten i think i wrapped up this
project um
late last year so since then i've got
another i mean
are there any commitments that i you
know need to focus on so i've not been
working at the same speed that i've been
working on this before yeah but then i
really thought about um how to deploy it
to the um to the general police
okay i think we lost him
stephen
okay thank you steven
[Applause]